[Music]
young rich Bryant and I'm Jojo
last summer we became master chefs of
the 88 rising summer mansion and this
year we're teaming up with even more
chefs and special guests and asking a
few of our 80 arising labelmates to help
us out welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion yo what's
good y'all this is dumbfounded this is
manna from the hire process and today
we're taking over feast mansion for
first we feast I come from China
okay Wow my favorite thing is Papa who I
love how everybody everybody might say
they love my spicy and affiliations but
we can't do that we have to what should
witness I'm here containing yo Jenny we
need some help I know you're from
Chengdu I'm also from Chengdu what's
your favorite hot pot restaurant in
chendo
never swung it is a man column yeah yeah
yeah I know that is like a famous spot
yeah everything and there's a lot of hot
pot restaurants in Chengdu there are I
think it's like over my song no no like
8000 is crazy for hotpot I love the name
- it's a straight-to-the-point hotpot
exactly like legend gendell we always
have our visa yo today's weekend we
should ha ha
even though today yo I feel sad the
celebration so in hotpot there's always
a ton of ingredients there's you know
that your meat your veg if you're into
like all of your innards
all your tripe and all that stuff good
stuff but my favorite part is usually
like the starchy parts like the noodles
and the rice cakes and I suppose um so I
thought it'd be fun if we tried pulling
your own noodles today for puppies
I've seen a lot of videos of this like
an ASMR thing for me you know but so I'm
really excited for this right here have
you done it before no no okay
let's get it usually what we do is we
start with flour salt water and eggs in
here and what we want to do is actually
like that's doing its magic right now
yeah I mean you can punch it it's
different it's magic right now and you
know it's resting so the dough needs to
rest in order to develop the gluten that
allows it to stretch really far oh well
but you know it's television into some
dough logs and he's arrested these have
fun rested now yes okay cool
so what you want to do is kind of just
like roll it out thin around the edges
right sick towards the middle you want
right it's like rolling your first blunt
you know
[Music]
if you pull it up to the light you'll
see that there's like kind of a strip in
the middle and that is that's good
because then we know it's not going to
break that easily so what you want to do
is you want to start from kind of here
and then you just kind of pull it gently
so you feel the tug of the gluten you
want to respect it you don't want to
like it's affected you know yeah be nice
gluten free head ass they don't respect
the glue exactly how you guys doing I'm
waiting for the TV magic to happen
automatically finish this in perfect
form
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so when you get really good yeah and I'm
still in training for that you can start
doing with dancing have you seen the
dances of Heidi so yeah I did see videos
were there I want huh yeah I can do it
over that and you're good when you don't
break the noodles right like if you
can't break it so I brought a friend of
mine who is actually the noodle dancer
at Heidi low laughing oh yeah noodle
dancer I want to see that yeah then
let's bring in the pro noodle dancer
that's like a thing at the restaurants
like this is actual thing yeah yeah it's
a job description like there's a that is
raised him so I don't know if you saw
what these guys are some Cory you know
some choreography fashion oh yeah Danis
exactly here we go oh this is totally
mesmerizing this is great you know how
crazy it would be if you could kill
somebody with a noodle yeah yeah yeah
noodle killer noodle assessment
[Music]
you guys want to give it a shot okay
here we go okay that's the maddest you
might want to stretch first you'd want
to get a cramp
Hey in that little pub yeah that looks
fire bro a fire it looks like a screen
saver like I yeah I like ham this looks
like it's a little bit I can't do it
like me for me it's just go is flow yeah
yeah yeah bro you lie to me
we never cooking huh it's like Old Town
Road lasso
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you my boy yeah yeah yeah this is
fine thank you
Jerry the noodle dancer ladies and
gentlemen I should wear this thing for
hide a lot so we got some friends coming
over I think we got the noodles down now
it's time to actually eat because it's
this is a community thing you gotta eat
as a family family style so let's go
[Music]
all right so we make these noodles
mellow we got some guests over here
jouji smoked part rich Ryan thanks for
having us Colleen thank you for having
us yeah what it's and on Chinese haha
yeah it's like a family style kind of
dish why don't you break down some of
the ingredients over here this soup
there's a there's a non spicy version
and then a spicy one and as you can see
it's like boiling it's ready to go and
all the ingredients are actually raw so
what we do is we actually cook it live
on the table and so over here we've got
some tripe we've got some fish balls
some bamboo shoots beef tofu vegetables
this one over here does anyone know what
this is that is actually pig brain and
it's thought that if you eat pig's brain
then you'll get smarter so whatever you
want more if you eat that thing so like
if you eat fish eyes you'll have better
vision why do we need to get smarter on
my episode
kind of chicken turner corner what I
like to do is make my own little bowl of
sauce so you can actually add a little
bit of garlic sesame oil scallions and
some chili oil if you'd like an extra
kick and then yeah shall we think in
real arts and crafts exactly oh the
chicken Center does not want it so
definitely don't grab it well this is a
scalding hot
all right so shall we dig in let's just
put whatever we want in here okay all
right well is this one fish balls okay
these are little mushrooms right all
right this is gonna take me a while try
the rice I'm pretty much whatever word
up you guys are like skimming me wait
that would be a good time to explain
that none of us use it very well let's
go let's go
[Music]
let's all try something at the same time
everybody got something yeah we go in
solidarity sure look it is kind of den
it's cool and this is good let's go the
pink bring you like that the pig brains
interesting by the lining now I thought
the pig brain texture is so like tofu
this is actually like a fish chicken
nugget that's kind of exactly what that
is located yeah that is really a fish
chicken nugget and a perp isn't better
than you expected
wait this is end of script all right so
I actually brought with me some chiffon
pepper they look like you know black
pepper but they're not a pepper they are
the seed of a citrus tree and when you
hear about like mala spicy and numbing
the numbing part is caused by this so
when you eat it there is like a little a
weird like tingly sensation on your
tongue yeah you know what this is
tensing I think I'm just tired of all
wearing rains it pours quite a bit huh
and it's amazing this later you Michelle
[ __ ] that's an intense flavor but I
already feel that yeah yeah it's like
it's like the right side of my tongue
had a stroke
I see you know I'm saying I see yeah
I see I was asleep woke right it's a
confusing flavor they I don't know I
really like holistic medicine
choooo choooo oh hey there's a nuts here
we're chillin right now I'm a surprise
final pitch you got this
[Music]
so now I think it's time for the noodles
that we made earlier yeah yeah oh this
is become one giant noodle now it's a
calzone okay
normally it would not look like that I
feel like Julie pulled so it's gonna be
there wouldn't they break apart natural
act in the that's what we could hope for
that's they will they will you know I
like that confidence like that I like
the texture it's almost like it's almost
like it's like southern I don't need to
put like a better texture now we get to
celebrate with the Rose sit the real
deal oh [ __ ] it's like buffalo chicken
senators special and buffalo sauce no
really I'm not mad at it is definitely
like you can tell it was dipped in some
Asian [ __ ] chicken fingers are on a
table because that's just like my go-to
when I don't went out like the food but
the reason why all of them are there
because I actually like the food so I
enjoyed it
he didn't I didn't think I didn't think
I was good I mean not like that I mean I
don't even I don't try new foods at all
like I promise I don't but that's my
candy this is that this is good time I
like you so that's our the table
yeah I want to thank our guests Joji
smoke purp rich Brian I'm with Melo we
pull their own noodles shouts - Jenny
our teachers today this is your new
favorite summer dish hot pot and going
every hot pot alone that is a lonely
life yo everybody got piece of food yes
sir there we go cheers thanks
[Music]